[موسيقى]
نحن نتطلع الى انهاء الحرب تماما وليس الى
هدم ولكن اذا كان هناك استجابه في الملف
الانساني فباذن الله تعالى نعبر
الاشياء العائده التي تعيد المباحثات
وباذن الله تعالى نصل الى
[موسيقى]
كان هناك نيه جاده لدى السعوديين والوفد
المفاوض وانا اعتقد انه فرصه اعطيت فرصه
للسفير السعودي لان يثبت جدارته في الملف
اليمني وانهي هذه القضيه السعوديه كما
بلغنا تريد ان تنهي الحرب في اليمن
ويبقى المفاوض
[موسيقى]
نطالبنا
المطالب خارجه عن المالوف في المطالبه
لحقوق الشعبه اليمني المرتبات في الملف
الانساني والفتح الاجواء وفك الحصار
واعاده
النشاط التجاري والجمهوريه اليمنيه
الجمهوريه
اليمنيها وهذه ليست مطالب الحقوق يجب ان
يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
هناك تواصل مع يعني كان هناك تواصل مع
السعوديه وعلى اساس ان يكون هناك الترتيب
معك قائده عدوان على بلدنا والتفاوض معها
نخرج من اطار التعقيدات الحاصله لانه هي
التي تجود العدوان وهي تعرف ماذا تريد من
الشعب اليمني ولماذا تحارب الشعب اليمن
الاخرين هو اما حلفاء او اجراء لا يملكون
القرار
نحن لم نتحدث بعد عن الاشياء السياسيه هو
في رؤيه الحل الشامل قدمنا نقاط عامه في
الجانب السياسي لكن نحن نصب ان يكون اولا
ان تزال محاجبه الشعب اليمني من خلال
الحصار وفر وحضر الاجواء وعدم تسليم
الرواتب وغيرها من الاشياء التي في الجانب
الانساني الجانب الانساني لدينا اولا
لانها تعتبر الاستمرار فيه الجرائم سواء
باعتبار خلال القانون الدولي او باعتبار
القوادن المحليه او غيرها من الاع
السعوديه هي جائزه التحالف في اليمن بعد
امريكا واتبارى انها قائد التحالف يمن
اشتد اليها واعتقد ان مصلحه السعوديه في
ان تتوقف الحرب لانها تنظر اليوم بنظره
تنمويه تجاريه اقتصاديه بحته
واستمرارها في الحرب يؤثر عليها قد يكون
لدى الاخرين ايضا نصائح نحن نتلقى نصائح
من بعض الاحزاب المرتبطه بعض الدول
المشاركه في العدوان والقريبه من السعوديه
بان تستمر الحرب لكننا نقلب مصلحه الشعب
اليمني على النصائح التي قدمها في الطرف
نحن قلنا في القضيه الجنوبيه انها يمكن ان
تعطى الحق زياده على الحق وظلمه
فتباحث في مساله القضيه جنوبية جنوبيه
ممكن انتظرك وان تحلل في المستقبل لكن ان
يكون هناك اطراف تبع السعوديه هي من
تستطيع ان تتحرك وان توقف كل اجندتها في
اليمن كنا على وشك الحل الكامل وفي
الجمهوريه اليمنيه اثناء بدا جمال بن عمر
وهم هم هم من توكوا عن يعني من اوقفوا
الادرع لهم في اليمن على الاستمرار في
التوقيع على الحبشي
اؤمن بان الشعب اليمني يملك جراره هو اننا
نستطيع ان نشارك كل ابناء الشعب اليمني في
الحكم وفي الثروه لا نريد ان نستبد بشيء
لكن الاخرون ما يرفضون ان يشارك ان يشاركه
فيما
نحن نقول دائما من يملك ضرارا من ابناء
الشعب حاضرون للتحاور معه والجلوس معه
والخروج بحلول
فيما يصلح فيما يكون في صالح المصلحه
العامه للشعب
[موسيقى]
المحادثات تجري في الملف والانسان وهي
بوابه الحلق السياسي واذا كان هناك انفتاح
على الحل السياسي وانا انصح
[موسيقى]
الوفود التي وصلت الى اليمن ان ينطلقوا في
هذا المجال بقوه وان لا يكون هناك اي
تراجع عن الدخول في الخيار السلمي
والسياسي ونعتبر ان اصولهم الى صنعاء هي
خطوه شجاعه
ونعمل بان يكون هناك دعم كبير ايضا من
السعوديه من زياده السعوديه لهذا السلام
بحيث ان نرى شيء ملموس على ارض الواقع اذا
لم يكن هناك شيء ملموس على ارض الواقع
فمهما توصلنا اليه من حلول
ستنصدم
بالتنفيذ في الواقع
نحن الان في مرحله العدوه في مرحله الحرب
ولم نكون نحن من يسيطر على كل شيء ابناء
الشعب اليمني هم من يديروا الشعب اليمني
ونحن لدينا كثير من الشخصيات المعروفه
سواء كانت من النظام السابق او كانت من
الاحزاب او غيرها تشارك بالحكم وبالتالي
نحن لا نستاثر بالسلطه ولا نبحث عن
الاستئثار في السلطه